[Musique]
alors je vais me présenter et ensuite on
va se présenter on te laissera de te
présenter ensuite andrea est élève en
terminale ce matin là elle se prête à
l'exercice de l'entretien son ambition
devenir cadets de la gendarmerie
pourquoi le gendarme parce que j'ai
aussi des personnes dans la famille x
militaire la jeune femme répond aux
questions des deux membres du jury
devant elle une gendarme et un
professeur 15 minutes pour parler de son
projet et convaincre de sa motivation
j'étais entré dans la gendarmerie parce
que plus tard j'aimerais le gendarme et
c'est quelque chose qui m'a toujours
intéressé et je pourrai apprendre de
nouvelles choses on va dire améliorer
mes compétences né en 2017 en
ile-de-france le dispositif des cadets
de la gendarmerie est un partenariat
entre la gendarmerie et l'éducation
nationale pilotée par une association la
normande âgés de 17 à 21 ans les élèves
sélectionnés seront préparés au concours
de la gendarmerie et des métiers de la
sécurité publique et privée au programme
de la formation cours théoriques et
stages de découverte en caserne je suis
amené à les préparer aux concours de la
gendarmerie nationale à l'ensemble des
concours de la gendarmerie nationale et
je suis aussi amené à aller à les ouvrir
à la culture générale au delà du cadre
scolaire voilà sûr on va un peu plus
loin sur la citoyenneté et le civisme
l'engagement les valeurs de la
république toutes ces choses là trois
stages au camp militaire de ben dans les
yvelines un premier stage d'intégration
pendant les vacances de la toussaint un
stage pendant les vacances d'hiver et un
dernier stage pendant les vacances de
printemps un dernier stage qui aboutira
sur la remise du diplôme de cadets de la
gendarmerie mais avant cela donc treize
candidats sont reçus le 16 septembre
lycée jules-verne de sartrouville parmi
eux ysaline devenir gendarme est pour
elle une vocation et ça lui tenait à
coeur d'arrivée préparé pour cette étape
primordiale dans la suite de son
parcours j'ai révisé j'ai fait mon oral
devant mes parents devant des amis
devant plein de personnes différentes et
comme ça et gérer une plein de questions
différentes le niveau est très haut on a
des candidats qui sont motivés qui ont
déjà fait beaucoup de stages qui sont
renseignés sur les métiers de la
sécurité notamment le métier de la
gendarmerie
ils sont pas surpris par les questions
donc et il est certain que les premiers
candidats qu'on a pu voir pour nous
c'est un mal mais c'est super quoi
onze jours plus tard il n'est donc pas
surprenant de retrouver andrea et
isaline parmi les personnes retenues le
27 septembre 70 cas des signes leur
engagement pour l'année une cérémonie
dans le grand amphithéâtre de la
sorbonne à paris
c'était une belle cérémonie je pense que
c'est quelque chose qu'on vivra juste
une scène fois aux nazis
et c'était très beau très émouvante et
surtout très encourageante partout cette
année sept lycées font partie du
dispositif dont jules verne à
sartrouville et louis blériot à trappes
120 places sont ouvertes en
ile-de-france contre 35 l'an passé grâce
notamment au soutien de la région deux
cent mille euros pour cette nouvelle
promotion et féliciter parce que c'est
un engagement volontaire donc ce sont
des jeunes qui veulent dédié de leur
temps pour les autres il ya un don de
soi il ya des qualités d'altruisme puis
découvrir des métiers qui recrutent qui
ont besoin de troupes et donc ça je
pense que c'est gagnant gagnant pour les
60 places restantes une seconde session
de recrutement va se dérouler avec les
associations partenaires du dispositif
les cadets ont désormais démarrer leurs
heures de cours en attendant leur
premier stage en internat rendez-vous au
camp militaire de ben pendant les
vacances de la toussaint
[Musique]